We are sitting with them
Who are they?
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
Ye, ye, ye
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
Ye, ye, ye
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
I am asking
Okay, it's like they're going
Behind our backs, hey
Bring them we're not afraid, hey
We are united as a team, hey
They can't see us apart, hey
Find us at the top, we haven't moved, hey
They tried us and got tired, hey
If it's in a hurry
They get left behind, hey
All their sins will beat them
You'll never see me betray my own
And my affairs should always be mine
Indeed, I protect my family
I also have to improve my own
You'll never see me betray my own
And my affairs should always be mine
Indeed, I protect my family
I also have to improve my own
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
Ye, ye, ye
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
Ye, ye, ye
I believe, I believe
I believe, I believe, I believe
In love and loyalty, ye, ye, ye
I ask, who belongs to whom?
Gqulu's doing too much
Killing them out here with guns and ammo
Mphela's doing the most
You'd think you can touch her
If you tried her
Stunna's causing havoc
While you're eating
He's spitting it all out
Sino's working miracles
You'd be suspicious of him
It's like he was born in a kraal
We met across oceans
We shared our power
Without carrying anything
We met them across the oceans
We did our thing, we gave it to them
We met them across oceans
Gave them what they needed
And healed them! How? Ha!
We are sitting with them
Who are they?